bella tutti ragazzi e beve siamo video
sono fa vj ci siamo su ipad
non so come si pronuncia questa roba
questo gioco qui che dovrebbe essere una
roba tipo non lo so dovrebbe essere tipo
play game ancora non ho capito come
fattori preciso ma va bene è una che è
praticamente ragazze schivare si cosi
non è ebbene è semplice non dovevo dirlo
a questa cosa verrà dal aperta i'm devo
fare le cose in tempo a figo devo finire
livelli in tempo in poche parole anta
stico poi sono morto un [ __ ] la
figura di merda giornaliera già l'ho
fatta perfetto ho vinto ci ho messo tipo
un'ora e mezza al posto di 18 secondi ma
ok morti 2 circa 4 secondi in un livello
che era da [ __ ] level nuovi
moving objects ok si può non riuscire a
fare star o niente è così facile come
porca [ __ ] i secondi il bello che ci
dovrei mettere 20 secondi per questa
cosa si gioca non fate domande non so
come ho fatto ma va bene 36 secondi
meglio di prima e la madonna 45 secondi
che cos'è una merda ecco che riparto da
lì che non riesco a farmi m mi sta
prendendo per il collo è veramente c'è
ma come potrei mai nella vita non si può
fare sto schifo
si si è fatta ac di tua madre o le
attenzioni ragazzi voleva [ __ ] non è
possibile apartitica siena roba
indecente
sì se 12 ore e mezzo per fare sta roba
impossi non ho messo c poi non ho messo
il [ __ ] checkpoint non ho più check
point ragazzi potrebbe essere un
problema in realtà volevo farle in 45
secondi siamo a due minuti e mezzo
il che potrebbe essere un problema ma va
bene che è bello 4 fottute ora e mezza
però ok una stella vita sono nella
prossima volta ci dovrebbe essere
scritto pietà perché tragico creati sono
solo un fenomeno sto già caccia partiti
a parte questo schifose
mi sparano anche addosso ci mancava solo
quello invece ma guardano come si destra
e cos'è un'atomica ce l'ho fatta ragazzi
già super record record senza morire mai
vai vai forza non ne hai chiedergli come
lo stessi facendo ma lo stessi facendo
un ok bravo peccato perché vinca questa
era partito bene non voglio metterlo su
facebook tua madre su facebook ragazzi è
veramente veramente difficile a parte
gli scherzi sta roba cioè non 2 vado
andati sopra ma sei serio
cos'è dove sto se va beh ma neanche chi
mangia vitasnella passa da dei ragazzi
urca [ __ ] c'e la stavo facendo non
chiedetemi come no sì sì sì godo godo e
godo sorella bye bye bye bye bye
affanculo diverso non c'è verso si vuole
ole ole ole l'ho capito magnete non
voglio sapere che cosa serve ma non ma
vicino perché ovviamente mi attira la
chiami su una chiave
ecco la chiave vai con la chiave aperto
sì ma veloce cazzo me ne frega niente
nell'animazione passa che fai veloce pro
furka [ __ ] ma lo riprenderà chi è che
cazzo non c'è non c'entrano mai più
nella vita lo sai vero ma non un cazzo
dell'animazione famiglie andare veloce
sì sì sì
vai vai vai 41 43 stava accadendo
microfono va come ho fatto attraverso
gioco io che problemi nella vita
tanti ne ho non proprio tanti sito è ma
sei serio sono stato ucciso da una bomba
cazzo va bene ma ovvio ma se siete serie
che ha fatto sto gioco ma chi
provinciale nel cervello ce l'ho fatta
non chiedetemi come non sono molto ma
anche una volta in sta partendo livelli
non lo so è veramente o quasi non ce
l'ho fatta anche abbastanza in tempo più
o meno cioè io veramente non lo voglio
facebook te lo devi infilare nel cuore a
parte la difficoltà ragazzi che carino
se non fosse che mi incazzo live ai bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye così a
caso a caso scrivo tutto cos'è cos'è sta
roba
son più piccolo bello sì vabbè ma ci
metterò leonora gancia farò mai dato ok
ok grande
grandissimo la vita lo sto scoprendo la
mia tastiera ma non fateci caso non
sparate non sparate sono innocente merda
va beh sì sì ai cazzotti no si è il
bello è che ancora non è scaduto il
tempo sono molto 47 volte ma niente ce
la puoi fare a passare il no non ce la
può fare
sì sì già fatta ma che si dovrebbero di
bella che si dovrebbe fare senza check
point senza tutta la veloce
ok il bello ragazzi che più va davanti
più livelli sono incasina c'è manca
adesso questo due minuti per finirlo
certo non sapevo io lo sapevo anche però
non ho messi checkpoint perché ciò la
cervello di una nutria o anche senso dei
soldi per comprare questo gioco c'è chi
chiunque l'abbia fatto e spero che tu
che lei ricevuti gli usi per pagarti le
sedute dallo psichiatra se ne hai voglia
ero passato sono passato di verdura sono
passati niente non mi apre ok non mi ha
preso no no come faccio a passarvi qua
come faccio possono seriamente se il
bella che dovrei farlo in due minuti
veramente c'è questi sono convinti
proprio mai convinto che cazzo ragazzi
hai rotto le palle però se acquistiamo
oppure così tranquillo io ho messo il
check point dove non posso più recupera
religioso [ __ ] ragazzi ho messo
all share point in un punto dove
continua a morire sapete cosa significa
che devono iniziare tutto il livello
basso la famiglia posso fare in tempo si
no so me lo devo troppo rivedere story
top solo per le reaction e non si può e
cosa dovrei fare me lo invento lo spazio
bye bye bye bye bye bye vice e come come
dovrei fare senza che poi non ce la farò
mai da ciò faccio invece la faccio
sì sì sì sì
ecco cos'è sta roba due minuti e
quindici sempre più lunghi ragazzi
convinto che questo era per
l'eccitazione del livello
rendetevi conto ragazzi che ciò 10
checkpoint di oggi voglio solo fare
immaginare quante lungo sto livello deve
andare le indicazioni incroci un
cartello sbagliato strada li mortacci
tua
madonna la mia verifica di matematica
era più facile di questa roba eh sì
invece la madonna come tagliare i
capelli zio guarda che non sto bravo
grande a cazzo non possono mai non
possono mai hanno battuto e la madonna
se già fatto grandissimo ragazzo ce la
posso fare
mica sto scrivendo cose che sembrano
ciliegie non ho capito ma quest'anno va
bene mi porta mai vai vai vai eccolo
bravo zio bravo rende fiero fa vj come
sono passato ragazzi se si da da cazzo
no non muoio muoio muoio muoio muoio
muoio muoio muoio muoio muoio muoio
muoio muoio vogliono muoio vogliono
muoiono muoio muoio muoio checkpoint
esplode anche il fratello apprezzate
l'impegno ragazza ho provato due minuti
e 18 per 3 secondi non ce l'ho fatta con
il tempo ma va bene te lo devi infilare
nel culo facebook e giocate a tutte le
ragazze ragazze giocata sto gioco prima
di avere il ciclo provateci giuro che
non ne risentirete per niente non lo so
perché non un ciclo ai beh eccoci qua ho
preso un ipod
cos'è la pro ag è la mano a tutto lui
tutto a lui tutto la lui senza c'è poi
l'ho messo l'omesso che culo che botta
di culo che l'omesso la fine che potevo
incazzarmi leggermente perfetto il
traguardo mancano due minuti e mezzo
dalle corse prima che lo prendo ci
voglia negli anni da fare la fila alle
poste per il pin che la barca va
[ __ ] devo passare io parte il
proiettile l'ha presa per il culo per
eccellenza tartassare i maroni invece si
ok ok piano non lo so dove l'uscita ho
fatto già la fila alle poste perfetto
possiamo tranquillizzarci un attimo
prima a sepe grazie
non ho più check point vuol dire ok
ragazzi
sì io ti ringrazio guarda non stavo per
dire non ce la farò mai senza check
point a fare sto pezzo invece ce l'ho
fatta non so come una stella te la puoi
infilare dove sai tu perché i gial
importante che ho finito avevo paura di
non finire mai più perché ero incastrato
in un punto impossibile ma da questo 4
minuti per finirlo come faccio a fare un
livello ma bella invece sono pro invece
sono proprio invece sono però invece
sono una merda adesso non c è lo so
adesso adesso continuerò così bello
sapevo porti capitana numero così per il
resto della mia vita perché non ho messo
il checkpoint mi deve punire lo sapevo
che dove punirmi testa di me ho capito
che dovevo mettere cioè poi però devi
far pesare ancora così tanto che non
l'ho fatto niente
c'è vergara e incredibile adesso l'ho
messo sei contento c'è la mamma contenta
bravo reja è il suo gioco e l'ansia
fatta gioco bravo zio bravo vai giù
veloce semi se mi prende mi incazzo è
fatto riprendere assicuro mia prenderò
pronta a schivarlo come un fenomeno che
non hanno stilato una sega
sono passato di sotto abbiamo proprio
vai vai vai vai se cos'è devo stare
appiccicati come faccio una riga non ho
capito sta cosa lo rimanerci appiccicato
non è che frena di colpo e me la prendo
nel culo vero no vi prego youtube come
fa durare tre minuti e 45 un livello
regala un'altra chi ancora chiavi a mio
dio e blu la chiave non è neanche rossa
come la crosta porta se è certo e io
dovrei farlo in quanto questo un minuto
grande grande grande grande grande
grande vai vai se vivo no no no no non
dirmi che non dirmi che è quello che
penso
prega i temi che si può tornare indietro
col check point grazie bei ragazzi
pronto parlo con il creatore di ipad nel
raking su steam
sì ci sono io mi dica le dispiacerebbe
guardare fuori dalla finestra un secondo
fuori dalla finestra intende per caso
questa figura è chuck bass